the bread
Dr sajay Aya makes life and death
decisions every day his job is getting
harder as the population grows older and
sicker doctors are being asked to do
more with less at the moment the doctors
and the nurses together are struggling
to provide the kind of state-of-the-art
care that we are used to providing and
it's it's kind of uh unfortunate that
it's come to this
here at wolverhampton's new Cross
Hospital they've introduced Fellowship
programs to tackle the Staffing crisis
unless something is done there could be
000 NHS vacancies by 2036.
today we're announcing the most
ambitious transformation in the way that
we staff the NHS in its history
a 15-year government-backed plan aims to
recruit and retain over 400 000 more NHS
staff we hear time and time again from
leaders in the healthcare sector and the
public
we need more doctors and nurses to ease
the pressures and we need reform to free
them up to do their jobs properly
and they're right
it's hoped extra training places will
reduce the Reliance on overseas and
agency staff
we've relied on the skills and
dedication of Staff who came here from
the four corners of the globe to care
for patients and there will always be a
place for them in the NHS
but demand for healthcare workers is
increasing so doing nothing
is not an option thank you very much the
plan has to deliver for patients and
staff but faces challenges
for the workforce plan to meet its
targets it requires greater productivity
and efficiency but that's a big ask of a
Workforce which is on its knees after
coming through a pandemic and another
NHS winter crisis even the reports
authors say the productivity assumption
is ambitious
over 40 000 nurses have left the NHS
since 2018 going abroad or quitting the
profession Caroline Johnson is one of
them I was a nurse in the NHS for 17
years I was burnt out I had to leave I'm
never coming back to the UK again
after working as an advanced nurse
practitioner in London she moved to
Australia I get fatigued just thinking
about the NHS because of how much we
used to work how hard we used to work
how hard I used to put so much energy
into and feeling like you still didn't
achieve enough at the end of the day
plan is ambitious but its targets must
be met for the health of the NHS and its
patients
oh she's Joshy Sky News